Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
And I'm just checking in on.
You can't yell.
I can't yell.
I am in Cologne,
Germany.
Um,
and it is,
it is one 49 whoops.
Sorry.
One 49 in the fucking morning and I'm fucking wide awake.
I'm still on fucking la time.
What a time is it back there?
Nine hour difference saints.
To what clock gates?
About what?
Nine 30 in the morning.
I don't what the fuck it is.
It's about four 34 or five o'clock or some shit.
Anyway,
so I worry you.
How are you doing?
I made it over here.
The flight was a fucking joke.
I literally watched like I watched one full movie.
All right.
It was a,
I watched Dr Strange love,
one of my favorite movies of all time and favorite director,
Stanley Kubrick and Peter Sellers.
Everybody in that movie is fucking brilliant.
I watched that and then I watched a half hour of goodwill hunting.
I was like,
I have not literally not seen this movie.
Yeah.
Since I saw it in the movie theaters,
I've seen bits and pieces cause it's on,
but I never just sat down to watch it.
Um,
for those of you who never seen it,
he's wicked smart.
He cleans the floors,
but he's wicked smart.
Um,
so a little bit of that,
it was crazy because that movie doesn't seem that old to me.
I was like,
wow man,
that's fucking movies.
21 years old.
And when I was just seeing just a shot of the skyline of Boston,
how much it's changed,
um,
since then.
Yeah.
And how much it's gentrified
and gentrifying is Boston,
is that the white people became even wider for most of those,
uh,
most of those areas.
And then I watched at the beginning of pappy on the original with Steve McQueen
and Dustin Hoffman,
and then I fell asleep and just fucking woke up in Germany.
Um,
it's not that bad,
man was not that bad a fight,
but here was the problem.
I landed in Munich and add a connecting flight to Cologne and they gave me a
fucking one hour window to catch it.
An 11 hour flight.
And you're going to give me a one hour window.
I was like,
before you even get on the plane,
I'm like,
there's no fucking way I'm going to make that thing
so much shit.
Just a container of a headwind for 11 hours and I'm going to miss it.
And I missed it.
So I have fucking sit there in Munich at the God damn airport for like fucking
three hours waiting for the last little southwest flight I had to take.
It was like an hour flight,
uh,
up to Cologne.
Wasn't that bad though.
But I mean,
I was cracking me up.
It was making,
making me think about the way they play football now,
where before halftime you score a touchdown,
you down by a point and rather than going for the extra point,
they do dumb shit.
Like they go for a two point conversion and then they don't get it rather than
being tied up that down by one.
And in the end,
you know,
there's some country thing,
you're down by four points instead of three negative score,
a touchdown.
That was the travel version of that.
So anyways,
um,
I got to tell you,
I don't,
I never think about World War II until I come over here.
I watched that Ken Burns the war just like a 90 fucking part one hour each.
Each one was like one hour long about the war.
And every time I fly over here,
it's not till I get over Great Britain.
And you just think about those Spitz fires and the blitzkrieg and all of that
shit.
Winston Churchill,
then you've come onto the mainland,
you start thinking about the battle of the bulge.
Okay.
Dresden,
all of this fucking shit.
And I was actually watching this documentary here,
uh,
and it was in German,
so I couldn't tell.
I was like,
wow,
they're fucking,
they're also talking about world war two.
I figured they'd want to shy away from it.
You know what I mean?
The same way I don't watch highlights from last year super bowl.
I don't want to see those eagles win either.
Right.
Um,
but they were talking about,
I could tell what they were talking about,
cause I had heard about it before.
Is this top secret?
Okay.
Uh,
basically a jet that they were just on the verge of like developing,
which just would have been a fucking game changer.
Like how far ahead Germany was with all of their technology.
I remember hearing,
I've talked about this shit before,
like if you killed a German soldier was an American,
you dropped your machine gun and picked up there,
it says with like fucking liquid cool or something like that.
Um,
I remember hearing some German tank commander saying,
uh,
one tiger was better than three Sherman's,
but the Americans always had four.
You know,
typical us.
We just treated it like a food court.
We just piled on instead of the food.
It was a weaponry and were able to get them,
but some historians,
so I look up this fucking jet first.
Yeah.
German,
Jed,
World War Two.
Yeah,
this fucking thing.
And it looked just like the spitfire,
but it had like two jet engines on it.
So the only thing I could think like,
well,
what the fuck would you,
how quickly that thing could get up on you?
What would you try to be like Tom Cruise and that drug movie?
We just slow down and the feds got to keep going by you.
You know,
I think that's works.
If somebody is not trying to fucking shoot you out of the sky.
So I think that that's probably what they focus on over here.
They focus on how good their weapons were rather than their a
missteps in
society.
It was called the Ameesha Schmidt me is two six to nickname the Schwalbe.
I'm sure I'm saying this phone.
It's German for the swallow.
Um,
was the world's first operational jet powered fighter aircraft.
That's what it was like basically a jet powered fucking two seater.
A design work started before World War II began,
but problems with the engine,
which means people died testing it out.
Uh,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
The me 62 62 is faster and more heavily armed than any allied fighter,
including the British Oh,
jet powered.
Okay.
Gloster meteor.
Yeah.
Look at that big clunky hunk of shit.
Well,
I mean,
I shouldn't talk.
The Americans didn't have one,
but chase chaises is that an ugly ass fucking playing?
The German one doesn't look bad.
It just looks like they're,
uh,
what they had.
The English had the spitfire.
I don't forget what the,
we had the Cadillac,
I don't know.
I don't fucking know shit about this stuff.
But anyways,
I was watching,
I found that,
that,
um,
that was definitely interesting and,
you know what it is,
you know how they always make fun of the ignorant American,
the fat American and all that Shit.
You know,
what is the through line of cunty behavior is people getting off an
international flight and doing that fast walk.
I mean,
you see people cutting off old people in all of this shit.
Just trying to not get an,
you know,
trying to get as far up,
to,
to get through customs is possible.
It's really fucking horrific.
Um,
I always laugh thinking like,
where are you going?
Yeah.
They know where the fuck is anybody going?
It's already another flight in front of you.
You know,
we didn't,
you're going to,
you're going to get there first and you'd be first and fucking line.
Um,
maybe it works.
I don't know.
I don't life's too short to run through a fucking airport with your luggage.
If you're not trying to catch a plane,
you already landed.
What are you doing?
Just sit on your phone,
play a little fucking solitaire and then talk to the guy up there.
You know,
I didn't know what to say cause you know I landed when I landed in Munich,
I didn't know,
usually I have work papers and I was sitting there thinking like,
ah fuck man,
I don't have any fucking work papers and I get up there.
So I tried to look all chill and shit.
Right.
The lady doesn't ask me anything and the guy behind her is like training of it
and he's like,
oh I've seen,
she describes him,
did I use it?
And I'm like,
he's just trained in a man.
He's just trainer and I'm working up this lie in my head that I'm meeting my
wife and Cologne,
Germany and she's coming over from London.
Could could it be any more convoluted?
Like really you guys are beginning of your European vacation and Cologne.
Jeremy,
do you have family there?
Did they just put up a new fucking Ferris wheel with the ego where that fucking
giant there,
which I didn't know existed,
had no idea that fucking thing existed until I fucking looked up things to do in
Cologne cause I got a whole day tomorrow.
I just want to go out and buy a pair of fucking Adidas over here that they don't
have state side.
I'm not looking for 20 floors of horse here.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
so I make it through.
They stamped my passport,
I think I'm all good.
And then this fucking cop is just like a Guttentag hello.
And I'm like,
Hey,
what's up?
He goes,
away,
you're gone.
I want to be,
what the fuck are you going fuck with?
Fuck you mean what am I doing?
He already stamped the fucking thing.
So then I tell them to stupid shit about my wife coming over.
He goes,
is this the only place we're going to be a gentleman?
I was like,
I be Cologne,
Munich,
Berlin.
Where else?
And I'm like,
Warsaw,
Prague hungry.
Okay.
And he goes,
how long are you going to be over here until the 14th of January.
I was like,
yeah.
Then I'm like,
and he starts walking towards this door with my passport.
I'm like,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Here we go.
Right?
And then he just turns around and gives it to me.
And I was just like,
all right.
So then I text my fucking tour guy over here.
I was like,
do I need work papers?
And he's like,
no,
you're all good.
So I went through that whole fucking,
uh,
what was that movie there?
Okay.
Well that fucking guy,
he has the drugs tape to them.
Okay.
I can't remember fucking anything.
I ended up having that moment.
I didn't even need to.
MMM.
So anyway,
so I'm here,
um,
uh,
obviously jet lag,
but,
uh,
my hour is ready to go and I plan on kicking the shit out of people right
through Europe.
And this is going to be a thrash.
So my only thing I need to do is I need to get my Kiddo some shell toes,
get my wife some sneakers and get myself some sneakers.
And other than that,
all I do when I go to new countries cause I don't like clutter is I,
you know,
that little flag you buy that people so in their coat,
I just buy that thing and I've never sewed them on to anything.
I just keep them in a little plastic bag.
MMM.
Which by the way,
I saw this thing where people try to break the record to see all of the country
go to every country in the fucking world.
Um,
first of all,
I,
it's like what country do you come from where your country doesn't have beef
with any other nation?
You know what I mean?
Jesus Christ the way that they're fucking whack and people nowadays.
Um,
but anyways,
so like some people have done it by the time they're like in their twenties.
Then I read this one guy,
we say,
sorry,
daddy started to do it.
But then after he got up to 120 something countries and he realized that he
wasn't traveling,
he wasn't seeing anything.
He was just going there and just,
you know,
flying all the way to China and get like a fucking,
some fucking shrimp fried rice and then just flying on to Phuket,
Thailand and doing whatever the fuck he did there.
You know,
stand next to one elephant and take a picture.
It's like not traveling is what the guy was saying.
So I don't know.
Am I babbling right now?
I probably am fucking jet lag too.
Um,
oh my God.
Did you guys see,
I'm going to try to get more into like pop culture to expand the reach of my
podcasts.
Oh my God.
But Donna went up at this,
this legendary gay club and showed off what some people were saying with a brand
new ass.
It's trying to say she got acid plants.
All right.
And I'm like,
okay.
You know,
why the fuck would you get a brand new ass and you're 16,
why would you get a new ass anyways?
I don't understand that one.
You know what I mean?
I'm,
I don't really understand the tits.
I don't understand taking anything and putting it in your body.
Uh,
that you can't kind of get rid of,
you know what I mean?
Shit it out.
I mean,
you got fucking,
what did you know I to see what those fucking things look like.
But anyway,
so I'm just going like,
oh my God,
she's lost her fucking mind.
And then I find out that she has a new album coming out and nobody's really been
talking about her.
It was fucking brilliant.
I bet it wasn't even real.
I bet she just went down to a joke shop,
you know,
they're phony British accent,
put these fake ass in the back of me pants.
Promote me new album.
MMM.
What's her new album's?
What's this new album called?
Tough songs about coming.
Something about the,
some of have some about sex.
Um,
anyways,
let's see.
Fake ass implants.
Let's see what these things look like.
Are these like,
oh my fucking God.
Oh my God.
What enough.
All those a tit.
But that was somebody's ass.
I'm like,
why is this so much space in the bud crack?
It was cleavage.
Um,
all right,
this is just all calling out.
People would butt implants.
This is something that guys get blamed for it.
You know,
this is chicks.
Just this is classic chicken on chick hate and they're going to fucking,
they're gonna fucking trash sheets.
I want to see what it looks like.
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
That can't be fucking real.
I don't understand why.
Why do people do shit like this to themselves because of the pressure.
If fucking media puts it,
is that the pressure you gave into it?
All right.
This is a lot of pressure out there to have a full head of fucking wavy here.
You know,
this transparent fucking jackass doesn't give into it.
Why the fuck are you fucking blame society?
All right.
What do as implants look like?
Yeah.
Google must be like,
oh my God,
this guy is dumb.
I want to know what they look like.
People feel but implants.
Oh my God.
That just like those giant silicone fucking things.
He's fucking lazy assholes.
Just go do some squats.
Go do some squats and just admit that you're not fucking Jennifer Lopez.
Whoever the fuck has the best ass right now.
Um,
anyways,
dude,
I should do that.
I've been threatening to get hair plugs right out here in eastern Europe.
You know,
I'm not in eastern Europe yet,
but what I consider Easter Europe,
anything that was behind the communist block,
when I go to fucking the other side of Berlin,
the east side of Berlin,
I'm going to get some fucking take stem cell shot in my head and I'm gonna come
back with this ridiculous fucking lion's mane of ginger hair.
And you guys are all going to be like,
oh my God,
what the fuck did you guys see?
Bill's fucking hair plugs.
And eventually it'd be like,
hey man,
he's got a new special coming out.
Gonna I'm gonna,
I'm gonna fucking,
I mean,
Madonna's the master at it,
you know,
I'd be lucky to stick around for half as long as she has.
So I mean that's what you gotta do.
Maybe I should do it.
You know what guys?
I don't watch fight club because it triggers me.
It makes me not like my body and I just feel like Brad Pitt is just,
he's just,
he's,
what did they say?
He's just setting the bar too high.
I can't like,
I just don't understand why nobody calls these women out.
Like how fucking self involved are you that you're looking at a movie star and
you start thinking like,
Oh God,
I have to compete with that.
No,
no,
just appreciate compete with that.
You're not even in the same fucking solar system is that I can throw a football,
but I don't look at an NFL quarterback.
It'd be like,
why does he have to throw it so hard?
Why does there have to be so accurate?
Um,
anyways,
um,
Jesus Christ,
the Internet,
my gut comedians from a fellow comedian,
please stop attacking other comedians.
What are we doing?
We need to circle the wagons here.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Don't comedians get enough shit.
We're going to sit here and fucking attack each other.
The fuck are we doing?
I feel like this is like at the end of the Blair witch.
When those kids kept them,
ended up in the same place in the woods and they were losing their fucking
minds.
This is what's going on.
Well,
I don't,
I,
for the life of me,
I just don't understand how a comedian could trash another comedian.
Um,
publicly like that.
I mean,
amongst your friends,
you guys guys a hack,
this guy stinks,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
I like this guy.
You know,
everybody does that.
And every fucking but the to go on there and then to actually talk about what
subjects should or shouldn't be discussed.
I mean,
there's like comedians out there.
They sound like Tipper Gore back in the 80s when she was freaking out about hair
metal.
Okay.
Um,
I think there's bigger problems in the world than someone going on stage trying
out new jokes that he's not putting out to the world.
He's just working on them.
That's all that was happening.
Jesus Christ.
I think some of the fucking Shit I've said on stage.
Okay.
Just fucking around.
And it leads to something,
it's,
it's part of it.
So then it's like somebody saying like listening to the first version of a hit
song,
go,
don't make God.
That fucking sucks.
It's like,
yeah,
well we're working on it.
How the fuck could somebody fucking blow everybody's acting.
Not everybody,
but there's people out there that are acting like fucking
my God were acting like soccer moms.
It's just a,
it's just a fucking weird God damn time and any ways,
it's hard enough right now to try to avoid a fucking scandal you're not even
looking for.
We don't need to be attacking each other,
right?
So God bless all the comedians out there.
God bless it.
It whatever the fuck it is they're trying to do,
they're trying to be funny,
you know,
and let these fucking non comedians say what you shouldn't.
You shouldn't joke about.
Let them sound stupid like that.
Jesus fucking Christ.
You remember Tipper Gore,
remember that lady way back in the day.
Pour out.
You imagined that.
I bet he listened to all that,
but he listened at Motley crew and all of them back in the day.
Yeah.
Wish I could do a fucking Algo impression.
It's sync.
Fucking kickstart my heart in the Al Gore voice.
Um,
all right,
let me,
um,
I hate to set the other night at the comedy store
late night.
And I was just in a stupid mood and the piano player was laughing and I just
started playing to him and I said like two or three fucking things that I would
never,
I would never put in a special,
I would never ever,
it was just,
and it wouldn't,
it wouldn't even have worked in that room at like eight,
nine o'clock at night,
nine,
10 o'clock.
But once you go on the other side of midnight,
it just becomes like a different fucking thing.
No.
All right.
If anyone would have filmed that,
whatever the fuck it is,
I was talking,
what the fuck did I talk about?
Oh,
don't say it.
Don't say I fucking say it.
Right.
One of those sets,
if all of a sudden now somebody at eight in the morning is eating their toast
and then somebody says it,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
for as much as a dick is,
I,
um,
you know,
if I go to church,
if I ever go to church,
go like once a fucking year when I go there,
I don't act the way I act at the fucking comedy store.
Nor would I.
Okay.
And I wouldn't feel like if,
if what I said at the comedy store,
I then said in a church,
if people got offended,
I wouldn't then feel like I was having a Lenny Bruce moment and I was fucking
being censored.
Yeah.
There's a time and a place for things and it's just like,
you know,
to just fucking
take somebody there,
working on this shit,
doing what they're supposed to be doing,
and then you take it and fucking throw it in everybody's face at nine in the
morning on Twitter.
Okay.
Because he said,
Whoa,
no fucking,
it's like Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
It's a really,
people,
just to let you know,
making jokes about really dark things a lot of times is a way to avoid the pain.
It doesn't mean you don't care about it.
That's really the way it is.
Such like page one of comedy.
And if you don't understand that,
then you don't know what you're talking about and you really need to stand down,
I think.
Anyways,
there's my little fucking 2 cents of it.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I can't,
I can't fucking imagine.
Okay.
I can't ever fucking imagine telling a comic what the fuck they should be saying
on stage.
Um,
yet let alone trying to incite other people who aren't Comedians to fucking
share that point of view.
Um,
if I did that,
evidently nowadays I would be a progressive liberal.
It used to be the hardcore,
right?
What is going on in the world has gone mad.
Down is up,
up is down,
black is white.
What the fuck?
All right.
Dawlish shaped them.
And I'm not trashing anybody.
I'm just fucking say it guys.
Don't fucking pick on each other.
We're going to get enough shit out there evidently,
um,
from butthurt alley over there.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody Dollar Shave Club has everything you need to look,
feel,
and smell your best.
You never have to go to this store.
If you're ever pushing a mop,
it fucking MIT and you're fucking buddy itches and you kid fucking solve the
math problem.
It's because you didn't use a one wipe Charlie,
a little goodwill hunting little dollar shave club there.
That's called a Mashup.
I believe the kids call it a Mashup.
That's because they deliver everything you need right to your door and they keep
you fully stocked on what you use.
So you don't run out.
Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you need to get ready no matter what you're
getting ready for.
They have you covered.
Head to toe for your hair,
your skin,
your okay.
Just say your hair and just assume that people aren't bald who are reading this
really triggers me.
And I
really feel that everybody at Dollar Shave Club could,
you should lose their jobs so I can feel better.
Um,
your face,
you name it,
they have it.
MMM.
And what do you mean you name it?
They have it.
Even child pornography.
I'm triggered again.
I need Gillette to also apologize just because they make shapes stuff too.
And when I see that it reminds me of this region.
I'm sorry,
that was my impression of the 2020 around September.
If this continues and they have this new program where they automatically keep
you stocked up on the products you use,
you determine what you want and when you want it.
And it shows up right at your dealer from what,
once a month to once every six months plus with their handsome discount.
The more you buy,
the more you save.
And Right now,
dollar shave club has a bunch of status sets you can try for just $5,
like their oral care kit.
After that,
the restock box ships regular sized products at a regular price.
Get your start,
start a set,
uh,
for just $5 right now@dollarshaveclub.com slash bird that's dollar shave
club.com/bro,
this is how dumb I am and how bad I was at math when I was watching goodwill
hunting.
They have this amazing establishing shot of MIT,
some sort of giant dome,
and I didn't even recognize what it was.
I thought they were in Rome.
I thought it was some old building and then all of a sudden he was inside
mopping the floor.
I was like,
oh,
I guess that's what MIT looks like.
I mean,
I'd seen it.
You drive by,
if I remember correctly,
you could go buy it over a bridge,
isn't it?
Right off Kenmore Square.
You go over that bridge,
but there's always tree sort of obstructing it.
You know,
I dunno.
Math triggers me.
Butcher box.
Everybody butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and grass finished beef
free range,
organic chicken heritage,
bread,
pork.
The incredible quality of butcher box meat starts with the commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics and hormones.
Cook with piece of mind knowing you weren't eating healthy,
high quality meat.
Each box comes with at least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
Unless you're a fucking binge eating fat,
fuck,
then you know it's probably an overnight snack,
right?
Going to have me 12 pork chops before I go to bed.
Ah,
you can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork,
mixed box custom box,
which lets you choose your own cuts.
And now announcing our new brand of protein,
wild Alaskan Salmon.
This isn't just Alaskan Salmon.
This is wild Alaskan salmon now,
right?
You give this,
you give this fish a couple of shots.
It's shown it's tits.
I don't,
I'm sorry.
What's your box?
Butcher box shows they're pure sustainably harvested salmon from Bristol Bay,
Alaska.
Unlike any salmon you'll find in your local stores,
how do you know it's from there?
They got a certain style,
a certain swagger.
The way they move their tail.
Literally,
its red color means that this salmon is as fresh as nutrient and nutrient rich
has.
It gets,
oh yeah.
Uh,
for $20 off your first box and two pounds of free salmon,
go to butcher box.com/burr and enter bur bur.
That's butcher box.com and enter [inaudible] B u.
R.
Um,
all right.
What am I up to?
27 minutes.
Oh Jesus.
It flies by Liverpool.
Got Their first loss of the year.
I missed the game.
I couldn't find it here.
I was watching some sort of soccer over here when they had this really small
net.
What is that?
Indoor soccer looked like?
It was outside and there was some sort of basketball going on and they were,
all they were doing was speaking in German.
Everybody was talking in German and then the crowd was chanting defense in
English.
It's weird.
It's weird the words that come,
you know,
I mean,
I don't want,
I guess I use blitzkrieg do I?
I don't think I do.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah.
So I've just been,
I couldn't find the fucking game.
Uh,
congratulations to man city.
I didn't realize,
I know it was like a huge deal.
When they want an understatement.
A few years ago they came out of fucking nowhere and won the whole God damn
thing.
MMM.
And I guess they handle Liverpool pretty nicely.
Some sort of controversial fucking goal.
I don't know what happened,
but the way my brain works is like,
fuck,
when do we play these guys again?
And we got to figure out how to beat him,
or are we going to lose in the playoffs?
And then it's just like,
oh wait,
they don't have playoffs.
It's just the end of the year,
whether it has the most points,
whatever the fuck they call it,
which I can't quite,
do you get three points for a win and one for a decision?
I don't fucking know.
Dude.
I'm so fucking jet lag.
I just was on youtube and I think I just learned how to play snooker.
Um,
anyways,
then did they know they don't have to fucking play?
They could like lose to them every time they fucking play him,
but still when the whole thing,
okay.
Makes no sense.
That makes no fucking sense.
Anyways,
I gotta I gotta kill a day tomorrow here in Cologne,
Germany.
Uh,
what is there to do here?
Um,
is there a good sneaker store here?
I don't want to go to like the Adidas store.
Is there a place where they have like a,
you know,
a bunch of different,
like,
you know,
Adidas that you wouldn't get at the Adidas store,
like a,
um,
a undefeated type store,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
One of those types of stores,
you know what I mean?
The ones where the s the super,
super fucking crazy sneaker head,
tight fucking people go to.
That's what I want to go to because I have to come back with some original shit.
I can't just come back with a pair of run DMC looking fucking shell toes that,
you know,
my wife and kid could've got down the fucking street at the mall.
You know what I mean?
So help me out if you can send me a tweet.
All right.
And,
uh,
all right,
I think that's it.
Uh,
God bless you all.
thank you to everybody who's coming out to my show tomorrow night.
I'm so psyched to be over here.
What am I great friends in the world,
Paul Versey Club Soda Kenny.
We're going to have a great time over here and thank you to everybody that's
coming out to the shows.
MMM.
Yeah,
that's it.
Uh,
I'm really looking forward to this and uh,
I dunno,
it feels weird to end on something positive,
but I think I'm going to,
all right,
so have a great weekend.
You can't,
and I'll check in.
I'll,
I'll talk to you on Monday.
Enjoy the music and there'll be another half hour.
Great.
Greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon podcasts from a,
I dunno,
some fucking Thursday earlier this year,
boy,
uh,
years ago.
I have no idea.
All right.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built per,
and it is the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
January 3rd,
2011.
Did you guys have a nice new years?
Hope you had a nice holiday.
Seriously,
before I,
uh,
before I say country for the first time on a podcast this year,
officially,
that one wasn't official.
That was just me stating it like in a court of law as in I s the defendant where
he was coming from and he told me quote to go fuck myself.
See,
now that lawyer is not saying is saying the f word,
but it's,
it's not that example.
Make no goddamn sense whatsoever.
Um,
anyways,
I hope you guys all have a merry Christmas and a happy new year and all that.
Now that you're back at work,
you know,
is this a way,
this is a weird week.
This is another word week.
Last week was the weird depressing week.
Unless you're array,
uh,
a college student or something or you know,
a kid you live in at home or some shit,
then it's great because you've got time off from school.
Everything's awesome.
You going sledding,
right?
You make an ice balls,
you're throwing them at the fat kid down the street,
right?
The ice ball.
Fucking snowball,
right?
Put a nice chunk of ice in there.
Your packet with some pottery stuff and you say,
hey,
fatty,
you want to have a snowball fight,
right?
You Cute my God,
they're finally including me.
Jesus.
It's been so rough since July when they laughed at my man
down at the town pool and he thinks he's included,
right?
I love all the mean fuck's who are laughing at this right now.
And then what do you do?
Bring him over,
right?
He throws a couple of fucking Colorado snow balls now.
That powdery shit it.
Yeah,
and then you fucking set them up like Pat Patterson when he took out the fucking
brass knuckles when he beat Ted Dibiase for the Intercontinental Championship in
1980 but you knew that maybe it was 81 I don't fucking remember.
Right?
And you're fucking nail that fatty right in the side of his head.
He goes down,
he cries half his face,
goes numb,
gets bell palsy from laying in that half frozen puddle and all your friends
laugh.
You don't even help him up.
And he's laying there and his dirty orange fucking puffy coat that he just got
for Christmas.
Where does he go?
He goes back inside.
It's sits down and plays fucking video games until he's 36 and that's the first
time he discovers craigslist,
you know,
with a quivering voice
and trembling fingers.
He picks up the old rotary phone.
I don't know where I'm going with this.
I think initially I was going to make fun.
The kids don't even do this shit anymore because they're too busy being inside
playing video games.
And then it just sort of spun off to a Vignette of my childhood.
You know what's funny is that that whole thing never really happened.
I was on both sides of that snowball.
Jesus,
that was pathetic.
You know,
I think it's important in life to remember that at some point you were on the
wrong side of an ice snowball.
Um,
am I really just going to do the mock gave voice to just get out of every
difficult comedy moment?
I think I'm going to,
I've been doing it for the first three years of this podcast.
People,
do you understand that?
I am basically about a year and a half away from being five years into this
podcast and actually getting to do a reunion show with myself,
you know,
thicker head of hair,
five pounds lighter,
just as much as a Douche.
Uh,
just as much of a Douche.
That's something a 2011.
I would like to have more sentences.
That makes sense.
Did you guys make any new year's resolutions?
Well,
I can't hear him.
So shut up.
What are you an idiot?
You know,
sit there and rattle them off.
Look at that God damn cubicle.
You're really going to sit in that fucking thing for another year are yeah,
that's right.
Look down and shame at your belt buckle.
That's snazzy little belt buckle that you bought that you thought would set off
your suit.
You know,
make people see at the gas station standing there thinking that you actually
have some sort of a fucking desk.
Well,
you could look across at somebody else.
Will you wield a little bit of power?
It's actually creeped me out.
I don't want to make somebody do something crazy.
It's okay.
Uh,
cubicle is just a stepping stone to a cubicle that's even larger.
Yeah.
Um,
and then one day being the final three people to get the corner office and then
you realize that you've been replaced by a fucking robot.
Speaking of which,
I got to find this email that somebody sent me.
Um,
if I was organized,
I would have heard it by now.
Uh,
in the meantime,
my goals this year is I'm finally going to rehab the fucking torn abdomen muscle
that I,
that I fucked up at a pirates game.
Uh,
I'm going on three fucking years.
Three years ago I tried to show that I could go into the pike position at 40
years of age.
Okay.
Goddammit.
I did it,
but I didn't stretch at,
uh,
I think I talked to you guys about this right after.
I did it.
God Damn it.
I've been doing the podcast long enough.
Go back to like July of 2008,
somewhere in there.
I went to a pirates game when I was working in the,
uh,
Pittsburgh Improv and I wanted to show off what great shape I was in.
And here I am three years later,
still dealing with two and a half years later still dealing with that.
Um,
what the hell is it?
Oh,
they are watching.
Yeah.
So anyways,
so let me,
let me,
uh,
before I get into the conspiracy theory,
um,
which I took a break from in 2010 because I want it to actually enjoy my life.
Um,
yeah,
I want to Rehab it.
Anybody can give me some web MD free advice.
C'Mon.
There's gotta be a personal trainer out there.
I know when you tear an abdomen muscle,
you supposed to rest it and then after you rest it from one to four weeks in
court,
according to my stomach hurts and I don't know why.com he's supposed to rest it
for a one to four weeks and then begin doing some sort of Rehab,
which
uh,
you know,
I don't know how to do it.
I found just sitting there in the plank position helps for you.
Yoga people out there.
It's sorta like the pushup position,
but you,
you're,
you're on your forearms.
Um,
that seemed to have helped it,
but I,
uh,
I don't know.
I fucked it up the other day and it's really frustrating.
It's frustrating.
So anyways,
um,
yeah,
I went to rehab that I wouldn't want to eat better this year.
A,
I want to continue,
uh,
to not drink for as long as I can.
I'm going for a hundred days.
I'm going for 100 days.
In fact,
listen to this.
Fuckos I went to a,
I went to the rose bowl this year and I did not drink.
I did not drink.
And I know there's a lot of you who are disappointed that I didn't drink because
you want me to fill up your life with a hilarious story of me making an ass of
myself once again to kick off a new year.
Well,
God,
it,
I didn't,
but I stood around and I watched enough other people fucking do it and I still
have plenty of stories and I got the brain cells to remember them.
Uh,
so fucking awesome game.
It was Wisconsin versus Tcu and uh,
how was like most people like who the fuck is Tcu?
And then you look on the program.
Let me go grab the Rosebowl program.
Hang on one second because you guys just sit,
just relaxes.
I walk across the road
trying to find the Rosebowl program.
Oh,
here it is.
Look at this.
I found it.
I really need to get in with an assistant on this podcast.
All right,
I'm back.
So here's the Rosebowl program and basically
the rose bowl this year,
if you were going to turn it into an awful,
you're going to turn it into an awful made for TV movie.
This was a,
I guess it was a story about respect.
All right.
In that,
you know,
people barely respect Wisconsin because they never go to the rose bowl.
I can't remember the last time they won the big 10 championship,
but they finally won it.
They want it and uh,
they beat the likes of,
uh,
let's,
let's see you,
let's see who they beat.
All right,
let's go through their whole fucking season here really quickly.
Stop Rolling your eyes.
You fucking commy non sports fan cunt.
All right.
Start off the year they beat Unl v.
These are the cupcake games early in the ED and they beat San Jose State,
Arizona State.
There's a PAC 10 team.
Austin Peay.
Who is that somebody who's name did they play?
Like one guy?
Uh,
then they beat Michigan state,
then they beat Minnesota.
They beat Ohio state.
Right?
Big 10 Iowa.
Purdue.
You've heard of these teams?
Indiana,
Michigan,
one of those teams.
They actually lost two,
but I went by too quickly.
Northwestern,
you know,
they played some fucking teams.
T see you on the other hand,
didn't play shit.
Okay.
She down there outside of Dallas,
Texas,
Christian.
Oh Gee,
she's university.
And you wonder why no one gives a fuck about the mountain west program.
I want you to write me and tell me just exactly.
Okay.
Oregon State,
that's PAC 10,
that's Tennessee tech.
This is,
they're undefeated season.
They'd beat Oregon State,
Tennessee tech,
Baylor,
Smu,
Colorado state,
Wyoming,
Byu,
air force,
UNL,
V,
Utah,
San Diego State,
New Mexico.
That was,
they're undefeated season.
And they're sitting there scratching the top of their fucking heads,
wondering why there that people are questioning their record.
All right,
so here's the deal.
I'm sitting there going,
all right,
I like this big 10 even though the big 10 isn't what it used to be considering
they went over and five on fucking new years day,
um,
who doesn't like an underdog?
So I'm going,
well,
fuck it man.
I'm going to roof for Tcu.
Even though they have Christian.
Oh Gigi,
she's in the middle of their fucking name,
which,
you know what that means?
They automatically think they're better than everybody else.
And Jesus loves us best,
despite the fact that they're preaching that everybody needs to be more
understanding like Jesus.
Somehow they miss the irony of the fact that they feel like they're the chosen
ones,
like all stupid fucking religions do,
right?
Jewish people think they're the chosen ones.
Christians think they the chosen ones.
Muslim thinks that the,
you know what?
You guys are all a bunch of bags.
All right?
None of you matter.
That's why there's so many of us.
If we were special than only be like nine of us,
once there's 7 billion of anything,
I mean,
we're about,
we're not special anymore.
Okay?
Do you understand that?
Well,
like socks,
you know,
actually some poor people can afford socks.
The socks,
it's still important to some people,
you know,
and I went the fuck.
I'm saying it's a Tcu.
They got to Fucking pee in their bonnet about how nobody's respect in them.
So I'm sitting there,
this is before I talked to anybody from Tcu.
I just saw I,
you know,
purple and black does a decent colors.
Man,
I liked those.
Wisconsin.
I'm looking at all these fatties from Wisconsin.
You know,
walking around just horrible,
horrible shape.
I think when,
you know,
when Europeans look at America and they think of the fat fucks,
I,
I think,
I dunno,
I think they date they send away for a Wisconsin broach university brochure
every year.
I don't know what,
because Jesus Christ,
those were some healthy fucking people.
All right?
Evidently the recession has not hit Wisconsin yet because those people have
plenty of money for extra food.
So anyway,
so I'm sitting there and,
uh,
we start to walk into the game,
right?
Me and three of my buddies were all good and I don't name names on this fucking
thing.
We go to walk into this goddamn thing and I start looking around after,
oh,
after a wonderful tailgate.
We really did it up this year.
Plenty of booze,
uh,
which I did not partake in.
I brought a 12 pack of water.
Go ahead,
email me,
call me a fag.
I don't give a fuck.
I feel great.
You fucking cunts.
Look at,
I'm still defensive about it,
you know,
at least I'm one of those,
those,
I'm not a preachy,
sober person.
I'm not going like,
you know,
why do you do that?
What are you,
what are you running from?
I know why you're doing it because it's fucking fun.
And I'd still be doing,
if my head didn't get three times the size of its usual enormous size,
you know my head when I'm not boozing,
looks like one of the moons of Jupiter.
Okay.
I don't need,
I don't need to continue adding to it,
you know,
and then have it be like Pluto and then scientists can fucking debate on whether
or not it's a fucking planet.
All right.
You fucking fucking fucking,
there you go.
See I needed the help there.
The F word for me is,
is my,
my uh,
uh,
what are those things?
Is the HGH of my fucking comedy.
All right.
And I will continue to use it and I don't give a shit cause they're not banned
in my industry.
Um,
anyways,
so what was I saying?
Okay,
so we had a great tailgate.
We show up.
I became in the back way this,
this,
this year.
All right.
We parked right along the fence.
We were right near the clubhouse.
On the golf course and then you can,
I could literally see one of the lights that lights up the stadium,
so we were right there.
There was no way we were getting lost this year.
Actually brought a frying pan,
brought some eggs.
We had burgers,
hot dogs,
steak.
We had shit to throw in the omelets.
Cheese,
everything you want.
We had a spatula.
We brought tongs.
We had napkins.
We had a fucking garbage bag.
We had a grill bag of charcoal,
four bags of fucking ice to cool.
We had every tech,
we had fucking corn chips.
We had salsa.
We had two bottles,
a mustard,
Ho Jara fucking pickles,
ketchup.
We had everything we had.
We had,
we had real forks and steak knives for the stakes.
We had everything except for a fucking table.
God,
next year it's going to be the per every year
two bottles of crown royal,
a case of fucking beer.
We we,
we will ready to go.
We even had orange juice for the fucking eggs.
We will ready to go and we forgot a God damn table.
It's one of the ways we start the day off with one of the best fucking Omelette
you ever going to have new year's Day sitting on a golf course on a sunny day,
no one,
the rest of the Goddamn country snowed in screaming at some ticket agent that
they got to get back to Albuquerque before they yak.
You know,
shits the bed,
right?
You forgot a God damn table,
which isn't bad when you eat an Omelet,
but when you're eating a fucking stake that's an inch and a half thick that's
been cooked at best rare,
supposed to be medium rare.
Okay?
It was,
it was just medium rare.
What happens is you got it on a paper plate and as you use pressure to cut into
that,
it creases in the middle and you see this puddle of,
of,
of grease.
It just starts coming.
It comes close to your balls and then goes away.
Just like the tide coming in and you sitting there going,
you know,
I really should a just drip the rest of this grease down into the grass,
kill a couple of lady bugs and then continue on with the eating process.
But it tastes so fucking good.
You Go,
you know what?
I think I can do it one more time and then you do it.
And what happens if fucking rolls right off onto your jeans and you haven't
noticed.
I don't give a fuck what you spill,
where you spell it.
You could have your arms outstretched if you spill any sort of liquid.
It not only does it land in your Crotch,
it lands right at the head of your Dick.
So it always looks like you pissed you pants.
So that's what I look like.
I had grease on the front of my pants.
Um,
I mean while I'm sitting here watching all these Wisconsin fans walking around
and they got these candy striped fucking overalls,
they look like Richard Simmons shorts.
If you fucking mugged him and cleaned out his closet of early eighties fucking
gay us running shorts ever.
And you somehow turned them into overalls,
you know,
it'd be one thing of women were wearing them that be kind of hot,
right.
But there was a bunch of guys wearing them too.
They,
they all look like they look like it looked like a jugglers convention is the
best way to put it.
So I'm sitting there going,
man,
I liked the big 10.
I want to roof for Wisconsin.
And then every once in a while,
because it seemed to be like 80%,
75%,
maybe 70 at the smallest Wisconsin fans.
And then Tcu.
So you know,
who doesn't like an underdog?
Yeah.
So I start walking towards the stadium,
right at,
uh,
I'm thinking I'm going to go for Tcu.
Fuck this.
I helped us little,
uh,
mountain west,
whatever.
Fucking I ain't know a conference it from.
Huh.
Um,
I hope these guys win.
And uh,
I start going up to the stadium and,
uh,
one of my buddies elbows mean he turned around and he points to these Tcu fans
in,
this guy is wearing brown loafers,
these light purple,
uh,
like Corduroy Docker's with the TCU emblem.
And then like a v Neck sweater
and like these ray bond,
fucking risky business sunglasses on.
And He,
I like if you,
if you were casting a movie,
did you guys see Facebook?
That Facebook is social network.
Do you know how like the Harvard guys at,
this is what this guy looked like?
And I was like,
oh my,
are you serious?
Okay.
Is this guy and an anomaly or is this really what Tcu was all about?
And my buddy literally goes to me,
he goes,
that's it.
I'm rooting for Wisconsin.
You know,
I look at this fucking guy and I,
and I was sitting there going,
you know what?
I think he's right.
Not,
don't know.
Maybe it's just this one fucking guy.
And then I see another guy,
he has on a purple fucking blazer with gold buttons,
a white shirt,
some pleated slugs and low first,
okay.
To the game.
Okay.
And all of a sudden I started looking at these,
this,
not all of them,
but a good 15% of them are dressed this way,
looking like those rich kids who fucking,
you know,
uh,
air quote,
accidentally kill their date,
you know?
Okay.
And then they say it was consensual because she wanted rough sex too.
And that daddy has enough fucking money to get them out of it.
That's what they started looking like.
So I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Fuck this.
I'm out.
I'm rooting for Wisconsin.
Now we're in the crush to get in the game.
And I look in front of me and there's this pasty fat fuck Wisconsin
fan in front of me.
What the Wisconsin had turned around,
and I don't know if it was dry skin or Eczema.
He had a perfect band of it going around the back of his,
you know,
his hairline at the back of his head and the flakes of it,
we're on the back of his sweatshirt.
I know.
I hope you're not eating.
Okay.
So I'm looking at him gone.
Oh,
horrified.
Absolutely horrified.
And then I'm turning around.
I'm looking at these fucking slack and a sport coat wearing douchebags.
And at that point I didn't know who I was for.
I was actually hoping that during the flyover,
one of the jets would go into the crowd and they could just start all over
again.
It was,
it was horrific.
Worst Group of fans I've seen.
And in three years,
granted I was sober this time and I could actually remember this.
So I go into the stadium,
right?
And,
uh,
Lo and behold,
I'm in the TCU section,
right?
And I'm like,
okay,
uh,
I dunno if I liked this and I just didn't all signage here,
start here.
Take,
say
this girl like three rows back.
JCA come on frout come out
and I go,
frogs.
They had the fucking,
I didn't know what they were.
We've got to give it to Wisconsin.
Badger is a bad ass fucking Ama.
TCU horned frogs.
Okay.
And,
and that their mascot,
look,
I don't think it looks like something I'd like to that star wars bar scene,
you know,
and again,
it's called Frau come,
I'll tacy you TCU.
And I'm looking at the girls and they,
uh,
they,
they have their jeans
tucked into their cowboy boots,
like they're in that band,
great white,
you know,
and then on top they have like these dime store Dolly Parton cowboy hats on.
And I was like,
oh my God,
I fucking hate these people.
And at that point,
and I was sitting right in the middle of them and I immediately just became a
Wisconsin Fan.
Now,
in defense of Tcu,
I think if I was hanging in the Wisconsin section,
I would route,
I would have rooted for Tcu.
Okay.
I would have rooted for Tcu,
you know,
in the middle of me just screaming that tacy you come off frogs.
I can't tell if Nia just laughed or the guy downstairs yelled at me,
I'll,
that's a dog.
Okay.
Oh,
okay.
My fault.
Or it's Mel Blanc.
Um,
good.
Anybody imitate a dog barking better than that guy.
Uh,
anyway,
so let's plow ahead here.
So then I just sat there and uh,
just was rooting for Wisconsin and I just want it and I,
and I,
I just another thing too that's really fucking annoying about Tcu fans okay.
Is no matter what's going on during the game,
they have a reason to fucking put their hands in the air.
See,
can't see the fucking game.
Anytime it was third down they had this gay little thing,
well you
know,
you make the a I'm okay sign.
They would do that signifying third down and then they would just sort of shake
their hands like,
Ooh,
just in case you don't know what it and everybody,
okay,
so it's like third down and anybody who watches football knows third down is a
really important fucking down as a fan who played,
have paid a fuckload for the ticket.
You want to see what happened and these fucking idiots are so busy going to the
loo.
You couldn't see anything.
Then that dimension,
there's fat whore in front of me who from the size of her should have been a
Wisconsin fan.
But then again,
I've been to Houston,
Texas.
Okay.
Those people like their barbecue to the,
these are the people that really make America look bad.
It's the fucking middle of the country.
You got damn people.
I don't know what your problem is,
is because you're landlocked.
Don't they have swimming pools where you people could do a couple of laps people
on the coasts or in shape?
All right.
Seattle.
All the way down to San Diego.
These motherfuckers are in shape.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Ah,
San Diego.
Go right up to coast Los Angeles,
San Francisco or Portland,
Oregon.
They're in shape.
Uh,
Seattle,
they're in shape.
Vancouver.
I even leave the country and they're fucking its shape.
You start getting out there in Nebraska.
Our Wisconsin.
Huh?
Fucking people are,
are horrific other than Florida.
Florida doesn't count.
All right.
Florida is a,
I don't know what it is.
It's like the ball bag.
Everybody says it looks like a Dick to me.
It looks like a fucking 56 year old scrotum.
Just hang in there.
Um,
after the Dick got lopped off.
anyways,
so they handed out the like,
like them doing that third down thing wasn't enough.
They handed out these fucking little purple like rags.
Okay.
First of all,
stealing from the Pittsburgh Steelers,
the terrible towel.
They steal that and then the on them,
it said fear the frog,
which they stole from Maryland.
Fear the turtle,
right?
The first school to actually admit that they have a bad name,
a bad mascot.
Fucking name.
So then what day with this fucking fat whore in front of me,
I swear to God,
every God damn play.
Okay.
Her fucking team would be,
we had ends on seats were was in the other end zone at Wisconsin's 10 yard line
trying to drive in for a score.
Okay.
They're,
they're 90 yards away.
If you're standing on the goal line,
forget about being 40 50 fucking rose up in the Goddamn Stan.
And she would be sitting there
as she's talking to a friend too.
That's what killed me.
Classic brought it again.
She sitting there shooting the shit.
You know,
she probably went there for the tournament of fucking roses and she just kept
it.
And I finally,
I tapped her on her fleshy shoulder
and she immediately took it.
As I was saying,
put it down.
I said,
can you just wave?
Can you wave it more in your like in front of you?
Which this is the funniest thing ever.
She does.
And immediately realizes that when she does it,
she can't see the fucking game.
Welcome to my world.
You're fat whore.
That's what I've been dealing with for the last three fucking quarters.
So then what she did was she then switched into her left hand.
Okay.
Because not only is she a fat whore,
she's a dumb fat whore.
Okay.
And the first moment when I tapped her,
she was like,
oh,
this guy must be a Wisconsin fan.
You know,
cause he's telling me to put it down.
Then she realizes,
oh,
it's in his way.
Did she waves it in front of her face and realizes,
oh now I can't see.
And you would think at that point light would dawn on our fucking fat head.
And she'd be like,
oh,
I get it.
If I waved this thing,
people behind me can't see the fucking game.
Not this fat whore,
not this one.
She fucking puts it in the left hand and starts waving like that.
Like that's the solution.
Like she doesn't notice that there's another fucking 80,000 fans to her fucking
left.
It was the worst.
And it's times like those where I just a times like those were made for taster's
choice.
Remember that coffee just brew up a Nice Hot Pot and you just dump it right over
a fucking head.
That's what I would've liked in a perfect world.
And as she screamed
from the scalding Burns,
um,
she would collapse afterwards.
So maybe pass out either way,
she would be out of my wife and I got to tell you,
that would be the equivalent of three normal Americans who live on the coasts,
who lived near the ocean.
Hey,
you know what?
I just realized that's how I'm going to make my million dollars,
my multimillion dollars,
so I can parachute out of this God damn business.
I've been trying to come up with,
um,
some bullshit that I could sell for 1995 late at night.
And I think I just did,
you know,
I'm going to sell,
uh,
ocean water and little salt shakers for 1995.
That's what I'm going to do.
And I'm just going to go,
you know,
have you ever noticed how,
people who live on the coast of this country are in shape?
You don't now,
now just show a bunch of good looking people running down the street with their
knees nice and high,
like the Wisconsin fucking marching band,
which was the shit,
I'm just running down the fucking street,
you know,
high step in it.
And then,
uh,
the white version of high stepping,
which is basically ringing our knees up to our waist as opposed to the Grambling
black version where you basically,
you know,
you're,
you,
you couldn't do it in a dome stadium because you would break your fucking toes.
Okay.
Whatever black people we're trying,
we're trying anyways.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I would,
I would sell that and I would just say,
and then you get,
and if you know,
are you tired of being fat in the middle of the country and just so somebody has
sent a,
been taken a bite out of it and then just looking at the camera like,
you know,
throwing their arms up like woo,
yeah,
I am sick of being a fat fuck,
you know,
they have sent a bunch on the east coast,
wired on the west coast.
Why aren't they fat fucks?
And I'll just,
I just spin it.
It's because they live near the ocean and there's smelling that salt water in
the air and I just make up a bunch of shit.
I'll pay off some fucking people in the FDA.
Uh,
doesn't seem like a hard thing to do considering half the drugs that get
approved nowadays,
and I'll just say it's because of smelling salt water,
air that you're able to eat Cinnabon and shut off those fucking pounds.
And A,
I'll sell it like little bottles of fucking Cologne to every fatty in the
fucking Midwest and I'll make my money.
And then I'm going to move to Denmark and I'm going to pay 90% taxes yet have
free health insurance and uh,
you know,
and a little vesper.
I'm going to go around those little fucking a,
those little streets out there.
I'm trying to put together a Scandinavian tour,
by the way this year.
I'm really looking forward to that.
Um,
so there you go.
You know something like you,
I also lost interest halfway through that.
So that was the rose bowl for me this year.
Okay.
I didn't drink.
I had a,
uh,
I had a fucking awesome time.
I remembered the game.
Congratulations to tasty.
Yay.
Let's go froward.
Congratulations to you.
A horribly horribly dressed human beings just horribly dressed.
Trash,
white trash is the only way to describe what I saw it there.
You guys really looked like you never left the Greater Dallas area.
MMM.
Yeah.
I'm going to go out on a limb here and I'm gonna say I'm never going to get an
opportunity to perform at that school.
Cool.
And if I ever get an offer,
I'm going to be really suspect of it thinking that they actually listened to
this podcast.
Oh my God.
The dime store.
Fucking
every,
the woman,
women all dress like them.
That Dolly Parton movie,
best little whorehouse in Texas,
except they were serious.
They probably put out my best hat for the s one.
I saw a guy actually took a picture of him or did they zoom into my,
I have some video.
I got to give it to my web guy,
um,
of this guy.
He was dressed in a suit with a big black Stetson looking like fucking,
uh,
Jr Ewing standing.
You know,
if it was the early eighties,
I would,
he would have looked good,
you know,
but it's fucking 2011,
dude,
it's,
it's time to let that go.
Okay.
You're fucking oil man slash coke dealer.
Look from fucking 1981 30 years later,
you're still rocking.
That look like dead serious,
dead serious.
These are the kinds of people that think like there's that you can cure
homosexuals,
you know,
and uh,
like one of those countries,
singers like Nita hit,
so they just write a song about how great America is and that too.
And the fans are too dumb to see through the fact that they're just trying to
make money.
You know,
I lock America and if you don't lock it the fuck out cause it's the best goddamn
nation,
even though the schools are going down the shitter.
Um,
and just ignoring everything space.
Speaking of which,
I got a great
underrated overrated here this week that somebody sent in and you know,
you guys know I'm a moron,
so I couldn't put it any better than this guy.
Uh,
this guy says overrated.
The New Year on TV,
every fucking year.
All these celebrities come on and say how amazing the New Year is.
How is it?
How is it any more amazing than the last?
The population is still rising and people are just getting more fucking stupid
and fat.
You know,
for comedic purposes,
you sort of said more fat,
more fucking fat.
And stupid,
see the alliteration,
but fucking stupid and fat,
you know,
that's just like,
after you've gone down the roller coaster,
you gone down ticking the big drop that you get,
those little ones that don't even scare you,
those little bunny hills.
But if you say more fucking fat and stupid fucking fat,
fuck,
you get two of those in a row.
That's like,
that's like going right down the big one.
Um,
anyways,
I'll help you out here.
The population is still rising and people are getting more fucking fat and
stupid.
The banks are still stealing our money.
Our money spelled are our money.
And uh,
and the politicians still lie.
I don't see how it is anything more than depressing and pathetic.
Loved your special.
Thank you.
Um,
yeah,
I agree with you.
100% agree with you.
Um,
to the point.
It's so fucking depressing that I just got a dog a couple of years ago because
no one else seems to give a shit.
Um,
and in that,
the line of that,
uh,
here's some,
here's some conspiracy theory for you.
Somebody said bill that they uh,
he wrote,
they are watching.
And um,
I got trashed for talking about conspiracy theory.
I've been trashed for talking about those automated checkout lines in the
grocery store and saying that I'm paranoid and I'm afraid of technology and all
this.
Technology's just going to help my life and make my life more easier.
And why don't you trust these big fucking corporations basically is to shit the
people who give me the same way people gave me shit for trashing the jets saying
that the jets,
you know,
haven't done anything so I don't know why they're fucking Superbowl favorites.
What?
Because the coach said they're going to win every fucking game.
You're not.
This is,
this is the best way I can sum up rex rhyming.
Rex Ryan,
Rex Ryan is the Tila Tequila of NFL head coaches.
Famous for nothing in particular.
He's never won anything yet.
Everybody knows who he is in his hanging on his words,
like he has something to fucking say.
What?
Cause he dropped 9,000 f bombs on Hbo.
He's famous for that.
He wore a wig and a press conference and we found out he has a foot fetish.
Oh yeah.
Toss some right in there with chuck Noll.
Fucking ridiculous.
By the way,
speaking of that,
the fuck did you know the Steelers finally looked like the Steelers?
I thought that they were going to look like when Rothenberger came back,
that is a scary ass team and I know they would just play in the browns,
but when a Polamalu comes in,
the is playing,
it's an entirely different team.
So all you jet fans out there who are excited that you beat that team.
I'm telling you,
that's a different fucking team.
Um,
I'm not even excited that the Patriots beat him.
because,
uh,
I just don't think that this,
the Steelers are now starting to click add a,
they remind me of a certain giant team from a few years ago that no one was
really paying attention to and all of a sudden got hot December and Lo and
behold,
beat the 18 and l patriots.
So,
uh,
oh.
And speaking of that,
my season long bet with Paul Versey.
Um,
I want it,
I'm psyched.
I wanted,
uh,
I basically rattled off six victories in a row against the spread and put Paul
versary Paul Versey out of his misery.
You know,
the poor bastard the entire year really felt like he was gonna beat me just
because I had never,
I had never really gambled cause I did it like fuck it.
In 1989,
that's the one and only time I did it,
I had season tickets to the patriots.
We made the playoffs the year before and all of a sudden we were five and 11,
and I was like,
fuck this.
I'm getting some of my money back for,
you know,
shelling out 250 bucks for seasons
tickets.
That's what you could get back in the day before ESPN.
Overhyped every sport and people who don't even like sports or going to games
now.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I wanted to get some of my money back and I remember the buffalo bills right
before they became the buffalo bills.
They had all those guys,
they were a year away from going to their first super bowl.
Um,
four in a row when it for AFC championships in a row,
one of the most underrated accomplishments ever.
You know,
basically cause it got,
cause he lost four Superbowls in a row.
So I mean what do you expect?
But anyways,
I decided to bet the fucking buffalo bills that year.
This is off on memory.
This is what gambling does.
And I remember that was the one fucker week that Goddamn patriots showed up at
one the game.
So I couldn't even enjoy it
and I lost like 50 bucks,
which when you're only making 125 a week is a tremendous blow.
So I never bet again,
I never gambled against the spread for like until this year they had Paul Versey
who you know has been doing it for years.
Dude,
I called in,
I did this,
I did that.
You got beat by it.
Goddamn nerd.
I'm just breaking your balls park cause I know you're listening.
I know you'll
listen to it.
All right.
So they had golf.
I almost went 500 for the year against the spread,
which from what I've been told is,
is,
is pretty goddamn decent.
So yeah,
I'm patting myself on the back.
Uh,
anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
so I have to get trashed for all,
you know,
talking shit about all these corporations.
Yeah.
And actually having the audacity to think that bankers,
we're all trying to team up and have one world bank yet out to become the loan
sharks for not everyone,
not only individual,
but actual countries.
Okay.
Which is something that I was thinking about when I was at the Rose Bowl stone
sober and I was sitting there on the golf course and I was looking at these
houses up on,
up on the ridge of this hill that actually looked down on,
on the Rose Bowl,
the grand daddy of them.
All these people have a house that looks down on it.
And I was actually envisioning that those were all bankers up there.
And while the game was going on and 104,000 people or 96,000 we ever showed up
for that game was sitting there going fucking crazy.
One of those pieces of Shit bankers up there,
it could put his hand on his son's shoulder and be like,
see all those people down there,
they owe all of us money.
Okay.
They all owe me money,
son.
I'm getting a piece of all of their fucking paychecks.
And they don't even know it.
They don't even know that their daddy is looking down on him right now.
Now had it been drinking,
that thought would have probably caused me to,
uh,
you know,
entertain the thought of climbing up that hill and throwing a rock through one
of the windows,
which of course I wouldn't have done it because even my drunkest I am,
I am aware that I don't want to go to jail and get raped.
And secondly,
I really,
I'm not going to go all the way up that fucking help.
So what I would have done is I probably would have yelled at that kid with the
light purple slacks.
I would've commented really loud about that dude's fucking,
uh,
Eczema flaking off into the back of his God damn sweatshirt.
Um,
so anyways,
this guy sends me this email and he says,
build the vase in this blog.
When I say they are watching our big business,
not the Illuminati,
but they are just as evil as any bank or secret society,
okay?
They don't even need your signature.
Listen to this shit.
They don't even need your signature for these information gathering trader where
programs to monitor everything from where the device is to what your heart rate
is.
Thanks for giving me something to look forward to on Mondays.
Also,
I like your Christmas tree.
You should turn it into a walking stick.
Now that the holidays are over,
you guys are so dumb.
You guys are buying shrubs.
Do you realize that?
Look out your window and look at trees.
You can see the trunk.
You dumb fucks.
It's like,
you know,
you're morons.
Look at a shrub.
Can you see that?
You can't.
You're buying shrubs that are pruned into the shape of Christmas tree.
I had the information from an
actual fucking guy last week.
All right,
I bought a Christmas tree.
You brought a Christmas shrub.
Should go fuck yourselves.
But I liked this guy because he sends me this.
What is trader where that's the question I had.
Um,
you digital camera may embed metadata into photographs with cameras,
serial number or your location.
Your printer may be incorporating a secret code on every page at prince,
which could be used to identify the printer and potentially the person who used
it.
Now,
now the fucking morons,
the sheep out there,
it'd be like,
yeah,
that's in case she threatened the president that just doing it for the good of
all people.
Um,
if apple puts a particularly creepy patent,
I guess Apple's applying for this as a recently applied for the use,
um,
for,
you can look forward to a day when your iPhone may record your voice.
Take a picture of your location,
record your heartbeat,
and send that information back to the mothership.
This is trade aware devices that act behind your back and portray,
portray your privacy.
Now,
this is what the moron sheep are going to be to say,
well,
if he ain't doing nothing wrong,
what's the problem?
That's,
that's the philosophy.
That was the philosophy behind why they can record your phone calls.
Now,
if he ain't doing nothing,
we're tacy you come out frogs.
He ain't doing nothing wrong.
Do you realize how fucking dumb that mindset is?
So basically as long as you do what the people in power tell you what to do,
you won't have a problem.
Do you understand how dangerous that is?
Do you want to stay on how fucking stupid it is to have that level of faith in
the people who rule you?
You know what I mean?
You haven't noticed how much power can fuck somebody over.
Like for some reason we only seem to focus on when celebrities get famous and
then they wig out and start becoming these fucking mini tyrants.
For some reason people don't feel they just have like this because they wave the
flag and they,
they,
and they play those songs that make you choked up that they never feel like that
they'll have any sort of ulterior motive for this.
This is the type of technology that allows a small group of people to take over
the world.
Something that's sociopath's have been trying to do since the beginning of time
and they were never able to do it because at some point your army would be
stretched too thin,
right?
Germans,
the fucking Roman empire,
all that shit.
At some point the fucking Japanese,
all of them,
everybody who's ever tried to fucking do it,
at some point it gets stretched too thin.
So America,
what we've done is we,
then,
we,
we've,
we've done the,
uh,
we're putting this base here to protect you thing,
that brilliant thing.
That's how we got our world empire.
So we just have a base.
Then also we have these insane weapons where we can nuke everybody.
So we were able to kind of do it that way.
But the problem is,
is when you really get into sociopathic thought,
and just like those people who are so into power that it makes that Deckard is
they want to know,
they want to be able to see everybody,
know what they're thinking and know what they're doing at all times because not
only they psychos,
but with that level of power becomes this unbelievable level of paranoia.
Like those people with those houses sitting on the ridge looking down into the
rose bowl,
there's a fear,
like we sit there,
look it up and go,
look,
they got the fucking world.
There was a fear of when you attain that level of wealth,
of losing all of it,
and you,
you begin on this,
this quest to quiet your mind,
you want,
you want to get a level of wealth and controlling your life that you are
guaranteed that it will never go away in your lifetime or your kids' lifetime or
your kids' kids.
So basically everybody that you know and love will be okay and you will be okay.
You get into that psychotic fucking mindset and uh,
you give those kinds of people this level of fucking technology and you're going
to have a problem.
I think that's unbelievable.
But that this shit is,
so they have this,
this website here,
uh,
the eff electronic frontier foundation that is trying to fight
these things being put into,
into the,
the tech,
you know,
the cameras,
the cell phones and all that shit.
Like the fact that there's a tracking device in your cell phone.
Like,
how come we didn't get to vote on that?
How come we don't get to vote on that type of stuff?
I don't want people knowing where the fuck I am and all God damn times.
Okay,
and I don't need you to show me,
Oh,
we caught this fucking child molester with that.
So because of that,
now everybody has to be like,
give me a fucking break.
They always have like,
you know,
that there's,
a handful of good examples for that level of fucking control and then does a
zillion bad ones.
So I am 100% against the shit.
And,
um,
there's always been evil people in the fucking world.
There's always going to be evil fucking people in the world.
And when you get,
when you have this kind of technology that you're going to,
you're going to stop.
They're going to stop small,
evil,
like individual,
you know,
a fucking a serial rapist.
What?
You definitely want to stop,
all right?
But the price we're going to pay is you're going to allow a Stalin or a Hitler
Pol Pot,
whoever the fuck you wanted that you're going to you with that level of
technology,
someone like that could get in power
and run the fucking world.
So,
you know,
I dunno
and I,
I totally 100% believe that you could roll all your fucking eyes all you want.
I,
I honestly believe that.
And I also believe that the reason why there's so many of us right now and that
the people at the top are not fucking concerned about it,
okay.
Is because we're all expendable.
And when the waters rise up,
the temperatures goes up and everything,
they're not going to be the ones who are drowning.
You can guarantee that the user in our taxpayer money to build some sort of
something to make sure that they're okay.
And I think that their bailout plan because they know they can't stop people
from fucking,
because it feels too God damn good and Dixon pussies are readily available to
anyone.
It's like air,
you know?
Okay.
So I think what they're going to gradually do is phase us out with robots and
automated shit,
which is why I refuse to use it now.
How fucking crazy do I sound right now?
Has there been anything funny in the last fucking five?
This is shit that I truly believe.
Okay.
You know corporations own like the DNA of a grizzly bear.
That's why they don't give a fuck that they're cutting down its habitat.
They're like,
I will fucking grow another one in a petri dish.
We're trying to take over everything and then wipe out.
I think they're going to try to wipe out the poor and the middle class keep a
couple of us,
like a small handful of us.
You know,
the way that pandas are only in like a Zeus at this point or some shit.
I don't know.
Maybe I picked the wrong fucking animal,
but that,
that,
that's the direction I think it's going.
All right.
This your first crazy rant,
which was based mainly in gut feelings in a couple of emails.
But,
um,
I truly believe that,
and I browsed through enough,
enough history,
a Cleo,
what's up.